انتخابات التجديد النصفي مواجهه مصغره
لاخرى محتمله عام 2024 بين جوبيد ودونالد
ترامب
في سباق السيطره على الكونجز والولايات
يدخل 249 مرشحا لجمهوريا لانتخابات بدعمه
ترامب كلهم يرددون نظريته الشهير انتخابات
عام 2020 سرقه
[تصفيق]
جعل ترامب في الاقتناع بانه كان فائزا في
انتخابات 2020 شرطا اساسيا في اي مرشح
يريد الحصول على دعمه وبالفعل ردد كثير من
كلامه
[تصفيق]
اتهامات التزوير لم تثبت مطلقا لكنها تظل
روايه صلبه ولها مستمعوها في قاعده الحزب
الجمهوري المواليه لترامب حسب معهد البحوث
فاكثر من مئه مرشح للمؤيد نظريه ترامب
لديهم فرصه جيده للغايه في الفوز
بالانتخابات
وهي مناصب تنفيذيه مهمه تسمح لمن فيها
بتنظيم الانتخابات والاشراف على الفرز
والمصادقه على النتائج وسيشرف هؤلاء بكل
تاكيد على انتخابات عام 2014
لاستعادتها اذا ما حسم قراره بالسعي نحو
المكتب البيضاوي مجددا